hi conan o'brien here i just watched
household hacker life hacks part eight
and i have my own thoughts here's
another tip if you've got ice cream in a
container and you don't want it to get
freezer burn how about eating the rest
of the ice cream
if you have eggs but no egg carton use
an ice tray the eggs should fit in the
ice tray if they don't just force them
if you want to eat spaghetti but all
your spaghetti's been burned up because
you were trying to re-light a candle you
should have thrown away a long time ago
eat the candle
and finally if you're having some
trouble opening jars it's probably
because you have no nutrition in your
body because all your eggs are in the
freezer all your spaghetti's burned up
and you've been eating nothing but
candles for six weeks
so go to the hospital and forget the
rubber glove you've got much bigger
problems
well this is conor o'brien please
subscribe to my channel
you can check out some of my other video
responses on my youtube channel at
youtube.com
teamcoco and that's a good use of your
time